All right, this is risky. Monetization's
gone. So,
there you go. All right.
Okay. So um so this is a talk that I
gave at hardware IO um which is a
hardware security conference um last
weekend and I added this one additional
slide in just for anybody that um joins
this presentation and doesn't know what
fault injection is. So um fault
injection is taking a a microchip or or
some device and doing something to it so
that it doesn't act the way it's
supposed to normally act. that's like at
a very high level and there's all kinds
of things um you can do to it. You can
mess with it. Clock signals, voltage uh
you know rails that are going to it um
send electromagnetic pulses or or shoot
lasers at it. I even heard um at the
conference people were using X-rays to
try to induce faults. Um, and so
generally the the reason people do this
is um it could be for testing purposes
to make sure something is uh hardened,
you know, a device going into space or
an automotive uh car computer so it
doesn't crash when it's not supposed to.
Um, it can also be to extract things um
from uh devices. So, a chip might be
locked um like you know when they make
mod chips for Xboxes or PlayStations or
things like that, somebody has to
extract some information out of it at
first um in order to figure out uh how
to attack it. And so these kind of
low-level attacks are are usually um
kind of a class of attacks called fault
injection.
Now, there we go. Okay. So, when I was
in the conference, I asked people to
raise their hand if they know what this
thing is. Um, and so this is a uh a
fault injection device. It's called a a
PCM. It's it's used for uh injecting
electromagnetic faults. So this little
thing you see right there um would be
where you'd screw on a little tip, a
coil, and you press a little button on
here. Let me see. There we go. We got a
pointer. You press a little button on
here and you can send a a a pulse that
can cause a a fault. Um,
now a lot, you know, so this this device
kind of falls into not the same class as
like a flipper. Um, but sometimes people
buy these things and then you play with
it a little bit and and you know that's
it. It goes in a drawer somewhere. Um,
and it's kind of it's rare as I asked
the the group that was at Hardware IO.
This is a hardware hacking conference.
So like everybody's used the freaking
thing at or knows of it at Hardware IO.
And then a subset of people had actually
used one before. Um, and then a very
tiny percentage of people in that room
had actually used one to successfully
glitch something. Um, and it's because
it's hard. Um, this device is uh it only
can send one kind of pulse a second. And
we'll get into why that why that can be
challenging when you're uh doing fault
injection.
Now, last year at Hardware IO, um, if
you saw, I also have a talk here that I
posted. I hacked this, uh, automotive
car computer. Um, and I, and this is
kind of all the devices in that attack
chain, and I used a Pico EMP. Um, and so
it is possible to use this thing, which
is kind of a, you know, I'd class it
almost as like a a toy kind of device to
actually, you know, break into something
that is a that is a fairly secure um,
device.
Now, when I did that work, um, it took
an incredibly long time uh, for me to
break into it. You can see the pain on
the other live stream I did here where I
talk about just how how tough that was.
Um, and so I I basically the kind of
very high level of this talk is I
wondered if I could somehow increase the
number of pulses per second that I would
send from one pulse per second uh to
something higher. And so when you're
doing fault injection, um it can take
thousands, hundreds of thousands,
millions of of faults that are injected
before you find a place that that is
actually doing something you want to do.
So I mean, do the math real quick on one
per second. Um it could take your whole
life literally um to find something. And
so there's other devices in the market
um like a chip shouter. Uh let me see if
uh let me test something here. See if
it's working.
um like a chip shouter. Let's see if I
can share this uh this view with you.
Here we go. I got a second camera hooked
up. All right, this is a a chip shouter
over here. Um you can see on my desk in
this bench near the coffee that
hopefully I don't spill. And then here's
the other the other setup I have um with
the Pico EMP. And so, you know, this is
this is much lower cost, right? And this
thing is incredibly expensive, but this
thing right here can send thousands of
faults per second.
So, um it it basically uh you can attack
a device and and look for places where
there might be something interesting
happen where you can inject a fault like
crazy. But I was like, is there some is
there some kind of middle road um where
maybe I can go from one to 100 EMPs per
second and keep it low cost. So, the
chip shter is five grand. Um, I want to
do something that's cheap and and
something that, you know, everybody can
uh can do. And so I I basically landed
on uh I found a cheap power supply on
eBay and I thought like, well, I think
one of the limiting factors is how
quickly this little device can charge
its circuit. It's like an old camera
that you would get, one of those
disposable ones where you take a picture
and then you hear it go and it charges
up and then you can finally take another
picture. That's the same circuit they
put on this thing.
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> Um, so I mean you guys obviously know
who I am because I'm right here and
you're on my channel. Um, so I have a
YouTube channel. I share reverse
engineering stuff and and smart meter
stuff and and all that. If you're not on
the Discord or the wiki, I'll show the
wiki maybe a little later. Uh, those you
should check out for sure. All those you
can get to from just richesome.com. Um,
now I thought I'd add just a little uh
warning slide in here. Um, I generally
expect that people are going to just
kind of take uh safety into their own
hands. Um, and when you're, you know,
when you're doing something that, uh,
that seems dangerous, it it could be.
And so, you should be careful. So,
here's my warning. Um, I asked people,
"What what do these have in common?" Um,
and I'll let you know, I'll ask the chat
real quick, whoever is there, what uh
what do you think these things have in
common right here?
Let's go get some coffee.
Now, to me, they're fun. Um, there's
definitely a lot of fun that could be
had with uh these kinds of things. Um,
they can kill you
and you should treat them with respect.
Somebody said, "My ex-wife took them all
from me." That's also uh Yeah, that's
something that can happen. Um, high
voltage power supplies are no different.
Uh, you know, there's stuff in there
that can kill you. Um, obviously you can
have a lot of fun with them and so you
should be careful. So, um, you know,
capacitors, uh, like a gun, you you
always assume a gun is loaded. No matter
what, you never point it at something
you don't want to destroy. Assume a
capacitor is charged. Um, even if you
put a screwdriver across it, even if you
short it, whatever, assume that whatever
it is, if you touch it the wrong way, it
could kill you and you'll uh you'll
probably be fine. If you're uh unsure,
you never played with electronics, this
might not be the first uh project for
you. Um but otherwise uh I'm a fan of uh
experimenting and living to tell the
tale.
Um so I referred to the last talk and
this kind of period in my life when I
worked on this automotive car computer
kind of reverse engineering as the great
suffering. Um and and that is because um
last year I I basically worked on this
device and breaking in and and I used a
pico EMP and and I was working to
replicate some some work that Colin had
done in his Bamb Bam paper to break into
this um 5.566 processor, but Colin was
using a chip shouter um so he can send
thousands of faults per second to try to
find the proper place. I'm using a pico
EMP, so I'm literally one per second.
So, it's just agonizingly slow. Um, but
in Colin's paper, one of the things
that's mentioned, some of these
variables you can set is that the
voltage he was using to induce this
fault was 444 volts. Um, and the Pico
EMP can't do that. It can only go um
from like 50 to 250. So, I kind of got
like hyperfocused on maybe I'm not
finding this fault. Maybe what I'm doing
isn't working because I can't get to
this voltage. So, it just and I still
couldn't get to it for the testing. I
ended up figuring it out a different
way. Um, but I just was like
hyperfocused on that as a variable and I
didn't consider how much time I could be
wasting. um and that if I was able to
increase the frequency of attack, um I
probably could have made a lot more
progress a lot sooner.
Now, that's not entirely true in that
earlier that year I did start like
shopping on eBay trying to find some
high voltage power supplies. Um and and
a lot of them can be pretty expensive
because you need something you can
adjust from your computer. um you want
it to, you know, go up to say at least
500 volts. Um and so, you know, I wasn't
I wasn't quite sure I wanted to to spend
the money on it,
but then I happened on kind of this one.
Um and and at first I didn't know like
these were pretty cheap. Like you see
this one's like $45 and it's called an
electrofaresis
power supply. Um and and and I was like,
"How is this thing that goes from 20 to
3,000 volts and you can literally
program it and it's got all this stuff?
How's it $45?" Um and I think it's
because people don't know what an
electrofaresis thing is. Um it it
doesn't kind of fall under the standard
class of power supplies. It doesn't have
computer control, so there's not like a
serial port or something on that that
you can set it. Um but I couldn't
resist. Um, it was like you can see
there like 10 p.m. I think I was laying
in bed scrolling eBay and I thought I'm
just going to buy this thing. Um, and
like all things that get purchased on
eBay like that, it ended up in the
garage. Um, and and just kind of sat
there.
Now, you know, later in that year, so
that was January, June, basically, you
know, the beginning of June, end of May,
I go to Hardware. IO, I give this talk
about hacking into this automotive uh
processor. And there's people in the
audience that see this and see kind of
what I went through and the fact
probably I was able to achieve it at all
using this. Um, and so I I ended up
hanging out with um some guys from the
Chippy Partners. um and they had an
interesting project and anytime you work
on something automotive that that seems
to attract a lot of attention and so
basically because of this talk they uh
loaned me a chip shouter that I could
use as part of some work. So um so
that's awesome because this thing is you
know it's five grand, right? Um and I
had never played with one and once I got
it it was like holy crap. um the the
signals. So, what you're seeing here, um
I'll explain these signals here in a
second, but the pulse rate like just
blew my mind, you know? I'm I'm
literally sending one pulse a second
with a Pico MP. This thing is like
thousands you can send. Um and the
programmability, everything about it is
amazing. So, these four signals here,
this blue one is a pulse that I'm
sending like a a trigger. So I'm saying
I want to send a pulse this wide, an
electromagnetic pulse. And this is just
a, you know, a digital kind of level,
you know, 0 to 3 volts.
This is the pulse that's coming out. And
this pulse that's coming out, I'm
measuring with a thing called an Hfield
probe. I'll show you that here real
quick. Um,
it's this thing. You see that little
thing underneath there? So you have the
the red tip of the coil right there and
then it's going to this little board
that says new AE. Um and it's just it
you know it's in the middle of it. So it
it's basically just like receiving um
this kind of electromagnetic pulse. Um
and so that's what you're seeing right
here. You're seeing the shape of this
pulse. And then these two others are
outputs on the chip showner itself that
can go to your oscilloscope. And so the
interesting one in this is this green
one. And so this green one, you see how
it kind of balloons up here at the end.
So what it's showing me is that as I
increase the the width of the pulse
going into that coil, the coil at some
point uh saturates like it can't take
any more energy. And so you see it as a
spike on the current output of this
thing I'm measuring. So it lets you
basically put a coil on there, figure
out even like how wide of a pulse can
you send before it starts not making any
sense to do it. Um all these things
which just let you dial in what you're
doing. I mean it's like it's a sweet
tool. Um and so hang on one second.
And so you know I'm I'm just like my
mind is blown. You can also just
literally set the voltage in onevolt
increments from 150 to 500. So
everything about it is just like a it's
a great device to use.
So at this point it's like I can never
go back to this device. I mean it's like
you know I've seen the light basically.
Um, and so this for reference, like this
is a pulse from a pico EMP, you know,
it's like and then
there's nothing. It's not like just very
fine. And so as I'm doing this testing
um some of it for this talk, I my mind
was kind of even more blown like how the
hell did I even use this thing um to
accomplish a task? Like um it's just
it's crazy at all.
But then my brain was kind of like,
well, like why is it so much better? And
so these two schematics,
this one is the high voltage charging
circuit for the uh Pico EMP and this is
the one for the chip shouter. So it's
like, you know, one of these is not like
the other. Um, and so I thought like,
okay, like maybe I just design a better
high voltage circuit for the Pico EMP,
but but the reality is like that's a lot
of crap and then a lot of testing and
it's not easy to design high voltage
power supplies. Um, and I don't I don't
do that on a daily basis. So, I'm
probably going to spend a ton of time.
And I thought, well, what if I can just,
you know, take this thing and and pipe
it in. And so, that's that's how we get
to this point.
Now, uh I thought this was interesting
even as I put this slide together in
that there's really nothing else in the
market. Um you have the Pico EMP which
is 50 bucks and can do one pulse per
second and I would call basically a toy
and then you have the chip shouter which
is $5,000 and can do more than a
thousand and it's it's like an actual
tool, right? and there's nothing in
between. Now, there are some devices um
that are kind of like um a spin on the
Pico EMP um like the Faulty Cat um which
I I got hooked up with when I was at um
Hardware IO to check out. Um but it's
still fundamentally the same kind of
pulse rate, you know, from what I
understand. It has other cool features
on it like fault injection u voltage
fault injection and things like that. Um
but but you're still limited to this one
pulse per second. So, and there's even
there's ones that are like more than
5,000 companies that make stuff. Um,
Rescuer and I think maybe Langanger and
and some of these other like really kind
of like high-end tools, but they're
they're nowhere they're not accessible
to us at all. Even the chip shouter,
it's arguable how accessible it is to
people. Like, you could come up with
five grand uh somehow, but are you going
to spend it on this one device? Um,
probably not for just experimentation.
like you have to have a business or
something um to to justify it. It's like
so there's nothing that could fit in
between to fill this gap. Um so I'll
take a look in the chat here. Um
somebody asked is a chip shouter a
successor to the chip whisperer? Uh no.
So the chip whisperer is a completely
separate device. It's used for voltage
fault injection and and um triggering on
on certain signals to cause a fault. So
I actually marry them together. So, in
what you're seeing here and what I'll
show, I marry a chip whisperer with uh a
Pico EMP and that's how I do the attack.
So, think of them as as two kind of very
separate things.
Now, you know, the question for me was
like, okay, well, how much room do I
have beyond um 250 volts with just the
the Pico EMP? like is it can I only do
250 or can I push it a little further?
And so I took a look at the circuit
here. So this is the this is basically
it's like three parts, you know, that
are used for the high voltage triggering
on a pico EMP. And if you look up the
data sheet on this MOSFET, which is a
switch, this is where your coil would be
that the pulse comes out. This thing can
go up to 650 volts. The capacitor is
rated to 630 volts. these two guys were
just going to rip out and we're going to
put our high voltage across this little
capacitor right here. Um, and so it's
like, okay, I should just be able to
feed 500 volts right into this thing.
Um, and uh, you know, and so that's uh,
that's kind of where we take it the next
step. Uh, says, could you tell me what
is a cheap tool to explore voltage
glitching? Um, there's a lot of them for
voltage glitching. A lot of different
ones. I don't know all the names off the
top of my head. the Chip Whisperer uh
light. There's even another one that's
like in the $100 range. There's some
that are less, but the nice thing about
the Chip Whisperer is they kind of have
a whole education piece around it. Um I
know Hextree, hextree.io,
they also have some fault injection
stuff and some of their own tools.
There's different ones if you search
online that are kind of based on
Raspberry Pi Picos and they have what
you need on them. Um, so probably sub
sub $100 you could you could get some
stuff, but I would I would try to find
something that has a bit of an education
package or whatever around it. Um,
because you you need to have kind of
some known things you're going to work
against to get a feel for how it works
before you start attacking just targets
in the wild.
Um, but there's always a snag. So So
you hear this thing turning on? It beeps
unless it sees a load. So, it doesn't
want to work unless it sees a resistive
load. This must be part of this
electropharesis thing. Um, you then set
a voltage. So, I'm going to type in 100
volts here. Hit start. You'll see that
little screen up here go to 100 volts.
But then, if I short it
at all, like just for a moment. And so,
that's kind of probably aggressive on a
time scale. Even doing a tiny pulse with
a a PCMP, you see it's just stuck. And
so, it locks itself out. the only way to
get back is to turn it off.
So, those are these are kind of the
hiccups that I'm dealing with as I try
to hook this thing up. Um, and so I
tried kind of some some rudimentary uh I
mean, you know, this is pretty
rudimentary, right? Like these are my
quarter watt resistors from like when I
was a kid that's in a little kit up
there. So, I'm digging into the past to
try to figure out some way. So, I
thought maybe I could smooth out this
pulse. So I have like kind of a long
wire going from the power supply to this
header right here. And then this is my
simulated load. I then have kind of like
a pool of capacitance. So I'm trying to
say like the power supply supplying
voltage. It it gets over to here. Here's
kind of a little storage pool. Um and
then I go through some resistors. Um
just like I think this is probably 5
ohms these guys together, these two
tins. And then I go over to the picomp
board. And so I said, "Okay, the PCP is
going to see this dip as we, you know,
dump all the power into the inductor,
um, the coil that's underneath there.
Maybe I can just kind of soften that."
And so this works, but only at certain
voltage levels and only at certain
glitch widths. And so it it kind of
falls apart. It's not like a it it
doesn't solve the problem really.
Some of the questions, um, is it a thing
you build yourself or something you buy?
If it's something you build, can I use a
pico and some parts maybe from like a
old motherboard?
Um, yeah. I mean, you can you can always
scavenge parts. The challenge is this is
kind of high voltage stuff, some of
this. So, you have to look at where
you're going to scavenge the parts from.
So, like a MOSFET from a PC motherboard
probably isn't meant to go up to 600,
700, 800 volts or whatever, which is
what you're going to need. So, um, you
can always scavenge parts. You just have
to look at what you scavenged from. You
might need to find, um, like I scavenged
a diode I needed from a power supply
that maybe went to a dishwasher or
something. Um, so yeah, you just have to
look at the spec sheets for the parts.
Now, inside this power supply, when you
open it up, um, there's this board, and
this is where our plugs are on the front
you saw me plug into. Um, it turns out
instead of plugging in the front here,
if you just plug right here, this is the
board that's detecting if there's a
short or whatever. And so it just never
sees it. So I just literally clip some
wires onto here and then run them out of
the front of the box. Um, I'll probably
cut this and wire this one as like the
unprotected circuit and this one's the
protected circuit. Something like that.
Um, but now I can just glitch glitch
away glitch to my heart's content and
the power supply is completely fine. it
doesn't lock itself out or anything. So,
super super easy fix. And that's kind of
the nice thing about these older devices
is when you look inside this thing, it's
all completely modular. Um, and so you
can also take a look uh let me see here.
Hang on one second.
Um,
you can take a look here.
Okay. [snorts]
So, if you just go to the Reachesum
wiki, there's a biorad 3000XI entry. So,
if you want to kind of check this out
while I'm talking about stuff, I took a
bunch of pictures. I started reverse
engineering this thing. Um, and so you
can kind of see inside what this thing
looks like. I'll add more. I stopped a
little bit um because I ran out of time
for going to this talk. Um, but you can
start to see inside their pictures and
then um you'll see more as we go
throughout here.
And so this number like this 444, you
don't understand how ingrained in my
brain that is the the trauma from
working on this last car computer and
trying to figure this out. Um it's so
traumatic that this I was laying in the
hotel room the night before. I like
literally I'm going to wake up in the
morning to give this talk at Hardware
IO. I'm dead asleep. Dead asleep. Wake
up. roll over, look at the alarm clock,
and this is what's on the screen. Like,
I literally grabbed my phone and I was
like, "This is unbelievable." And I took
a picture of this thing and I went to
take a second picture that's a little
better and it changed to 445. So, it's
like just enough to tease me like, you
know, it's like the movie Pi where you
just start seeing crap all around that.
That's me with this number. So, uh yeah.
Now, um, this is this is kind of where
I'll show you a bit of the test setup so
you get a little more of a feel. Um,
the way I'm the way I'm kind of
conducting the test, what I'm going to
show you later, signals and things like
that, is I'm using a function generator.
And the function generator is just
letting me output a number of defined
pulses. So, here you see it's set to 100
hertz. So, a square wave basically at
100 cycles per second. Um, now that is
that's not the kind of pulse you want to
feed in to trigger this coil. I'm I'm
driving it directly myself. I'm not
using the pico EMP that's on or or I'm
not using the Raspberry Pi Pico that's
on the top of this thing anymore. I'm
literally feeding in the pulse that I
want to drive the MOSFET. So, I don't
want this crazy square wave. I want a
pulse that's like 100 nanoseconds wide.
This function generator can't do that.
So I feed it to the chip whisperer. This
is a Husky plus, but you can use any
chip whisperer for this. I'm basically
feeding it um a trigger signal and it's
taking that and it's allowing me to
define very precisely a pulse that I
want to put out 80 nonds, 90, 100, um
whatever I define. And then that signal
from that comes over here to whether
it's a chip shouter or a pico EMP.
That's the way I perform most of my
glitching attacks. I control the pulse
and everything from a chip whisperer and
I just send it to whatever the device
is. Um, and so a chip shatter has an
input on the top you plug in. This has a
couple wires that I feed in right here.
It generates a pulse. You can see my
high voltage coming over here into here
where I just literally it's soldered
across the capacitor that's there. I
mean this is like you know very uh very
prototypy.
And then this down here is the Hfield
probe and this is what's going to
measure our pulse that's coming out so
we can take a look at it.
Now, the goal kind of was like, could I
do like could I get two orders of
magnitude? So, it it you know, it does
one pulse per second now. So, if you
could do a 100 pulses per second, even
at the 250 volts, it's like you
literally your attacks are 100 times
faster if you sat and stared at
something for 5 minutes, which is a lot
of times what I do. I'm performing an
attack and I'm like looking at the
oscilloscope and I'm looking to see does
something funky happen with the chip.
I'll have a bunch of lines set up, you
know, a bunch of traces, things I'm
watching on the oscilloscope, and I'm
just trying to see like where where does
a fault happen. And so, you're you're
trying to move this probe around over
the board um and and figure it out. So,
at one per second, it's super slow. I
mean, if you just look away for a
moment, you might miss the one pulse out
of a thousand that actually made a
difference. Um, and so this would be
epic just to get to this level.
So, what you see here is I'm rolling up
the the the pulses per second. We're at
250 volts. And this is the shape of the
electromagnetic pulse coming out of the
Pico EMP. It looks awesome considering
and it's going at 100 pulses per second.
It's not degrading. There's nothing
weird happening with it. And I'm like,
holy crap. like just without doing
anything really to this board. All I did
was just change kind of what you know
I'm driving it versus the Raspberry Pi
Pico that's on there. Um you can just
step it up. All all I needed was an
external power supply to drive it. So
for 50 bucks 70 ship to get 100 times
the performance like this is you know
100 times better than what it is out of
the box.
But then like I think like we all know
um
that's never it's never good enough. So
I'm like okay well if I can do 100
pulses per second at 250 volts like can
I do 500 volts like we already saw the
parts can handle it. And so at this
point I'm taking out the thermal the
thermal camera and uh and I'm I'm
popping it on there because I know
things are going to start to heat up.
Like that's a lot of energy to be
discharging. And so what you see here is
it heating up. Let me pull this up here.
I'll show you I'll show you a live view
real quick.
Um you see it heating up and I'm I'm
basically starting to monitor it. Um and
50° Celsius uh isn't bad for, you know,
one of these little uh MOSFETs. And it's
it's able to uh it's able to do it. So
let's see what's going on with this uh
camera. We don't want that level of
zoom. Okay.
So, this guy right here is what I'm
using. And I pointed at it right now.
It's nice and cool. You see the power
supply back there is kind of warm, but
um but this board itself is is nice and
cool. As I kind of kick it on to start
doing some scanning, um we'll see it
warm up. Actually, here I'll I'll kick
it on real quick. It might be hard to
hear me for a second, but here's the the
setup. We set output one pulse per
second. Uh let's see here.
Let me let me go here.
We'll do this. Um,
you should be able to see my screen
here.
Okay, let's let's just uh go over here.
So, this is my serial interface. You'll
see it here a little more in a moment.
Um, but we see 200 volts. Let's set the
the voltage of this power supply to 250.
turn it on.
[snorts] Let's see here if it's uh
going. Okay, so we see now we're at 250
volts. Now you can see the oscilloscope
is uh has come to life. It's showing a
pulse. It's showing basically less than
two. You see the trigger signal. So that
little light flashing over here is going
at one pulse per second, which is what
we're set. And the yellow trace is what
you're seeing is the the pulse that's at
this 250 volts. Um, and so that's going
through here. So, let me roll this up a
little bit.
We'll just change this guy
to
let's change it to 20.
So, now you see that trigger signal is
going a lot faster.
says we're doing like 20 20 hertz up
there.
So, this guy will probably start to
Yeah, you're already seeing it, right?
So, it'll start to warm up a little bit.
Um, but not uh nothing that's too crazy.
So, we'll just let it uh kind of cook
over there. Um, and the other thing you
notice on this is like look at the shape
of this pulse. Like even as I got in a
higher voltage, um, it got it's pretty
nice and narrow. And that's that's
something you want when you're doing
fault injection. Like you really want to
control where the like the the the li
the size the width of the pulse because
you're trying to induce a fault but but
something very quick you know like you
want uh some operation stepping through
code of the chip to just skip like if
password correct go here if password
incorrect go there. You want to send the
incorrect password but hit it at the
right moment so it goes here instead. So
the you know the how hard you induce a
fault is whether you kind of reboot the
chip because you just slammed it too
hard or you cause it to skip an
instruction or or write something to
memory incorrectly. So there's all these
kind of little things here.
Now
I put this this is a a movie clip from
the the movie uh Top Gun Maverick. I'm
going to show you a section of it
because as you get to a certain point,
this this resonated very strongly with
me. I'm sure it will with you. Um, and
if you uh if you're watching this and
for some reason there is no movie clip,
I'll put a link in the description to
where you should go in case YouTube
slaps me and says I'm not allowed to
show this. But this is literally from
YouTube. So, yeah. So, here we go. Give
me a second to
to get this at the right point where I
want you to start, which is about right
here. I'm going to drop myself out of
here and you're going to see exactly
what I mean.
>> Come on, sweetheart. Just a little more.
Just a little.
Come on.
[cheering]
>> Put that in your bed budget.
Here we go.
Don't do it. Don't do it.
>> Just
a little push.
>> Holy [__]
You got some balls, stick jucky. I'll
give you that.
So,
I want to push it just a little more,
but but quite more than that. By a
little more, I mean another order of
magnitude. So, 100 pulses per second is
is great, but but like I it's almost
like I got there too easy. Um
Oh, I got a literally a warning on
YouTube. Oh, that's funny. Um, hopefully
it doesn't block me. Let me know in the
chat if I disappear for some reason. Um,
so, uh, could I push it to a thousand?
Like a thousand is a crazy, uh, a crazy
level. Um, and so
I literally, this is me rolling it up
right at the end there. Um, to try to
get it so the oscilloscope will say 1
kilohertz on it. And this is it going at
a thousand pulses per second in a
freaking pico EMP.
And now we see we're at like 140 degrees
Celsius. So now we're we're definitely
cooking. Um and and now it's no longer
just uh you know kind of uh what do you
call it? Uh just ambient open air kind
of cooling. I have a fan on it. The
fan's not blowing super hard. And also
that board is not designed at all. like
it's not optimized for heat, uh, you
know, for heat dissipation or anything,
but I'm doing a,000 pulses per second at
500 volts. Um, which is like the, you
know, the kind of the the highest
highend. Um, and and I have the fan on
there and it's been running for a while
like this. So, you see the little red
time at the bottom of the thermal. It's
24 almost 25 minutes. This is like I had
been rolling this up 200, 300, 400, 500
volts up to this 1,000 as I started to
turn the fan on slowly. So, it's not
like I just kicked it on for a moment or
whatever. Like, this thing could run
sustained,000 pulses per second at 500
volts.
Now, if that fan were to move, uh,
probably for a moment, this thing would
just thermal runaway. The MOSFET would
uh would destroy itself. Um, but I you
know, as long as you're actively cooling
it in some way and monitoring it, it
seems like it's fine.
But I still have a problem in that
right now, this is the way I control
this power supply. This is just how it
is when you buy it. Um,
so there's my 444. Um, and so, you know,
I when you're doing fault injection,
like you want to quickly change the
voltage. You want to cycle through
settings very fast. You want to move the
pulse as you're injecting it very
quickly. And so you're kind of scanning
a huge range like especially when you
don't quite know what's going on. You're
hunting for something. You might be like
250, 251, 255. And so this will not work
to like type in the the voltage. And I
realized that as I was preparing to give
a talk at hardware IO and I was like how
freaking stupid am I going to look if I
go there and I'm like check this out
guys and then type it in. So, I was
like, "Oh crap, I got to reverse
engineer this thing."
Um, which kind of comes like it turns
out to be pretty awesome. Like, I'm
really glad I did this. Um, so I popped
this thing open. And so, what you see
inside here is is kind of a a few
sections. This section here, there's
actually a piece on top you can't see
when I open it. And that's the um the
keypad, the screen, the LEDs, like the
boards that control that. And they're
all pretty kind of uh dumb dumb boards.
It's getting all of its signal from a
huge connector that's back here. This is
a computer. A Motorola 6800 processor is
on this. Um, and so this is the computer
controlled part of this power supply. It
comes through a cable right here over
plugs into this board. And this is like
the high voltage um control board. It's
doing all the coordination, the
measurement, the the driving that that
ultimately drives this which is what's
doing the high voltage generation. We
already saw this board which is trying
to protect us from ourselves and then
out the front uh comes high high voltage
right there.
Now um a little deeper
uh like I said the the computer part of
it and the high voltage part so kind of
like over here versus over there are
separate. Um that's really cool. Also
this right here, these are optoouplers.
And so what they do is they isolate like
literally physically isolate one part of
a circuit from another. So uh the the
computer part isn't uh getting into this
high voltage part. And they do that by
literally there's like inside of this
little white package, it's it's
literally a light on one side and a
receiver on the other. And so one side
flashes the light and the other side
sees it almost like it's sending Morris
code back and forth and there's a
physical air gap in between there. And
so what the computer sends is it sets a
digital to analog converter which is
what sets the voltage level. And what
the what the board sends back is a
couple of pulse mod pulse with modulated
signals that tell you the voltage level,
the current um output, and then three
kind of digital IO's, which is is the
power supply shorted? Is it open? And
then there's one I don't know what it
does. Um I I think it's maybe a ground
fault thing based on what the manual
says. And so what I did was replace this
big stock computer um with a Raspberry
Pi Pico.
Now, like I said, you can you can go
over to the wiki. You can check this
out. I have some of the the boards um
like the computer itself and this high
voltage um kind of driver board which is
the the most critical one. And then this
here is really the connector we tap into
and its pin out is um is listed on the
wiki there. So you can see what that is
if you want to do your own driving or uh
modify what I've done.
Now how I figured it out um was I just
literally made an interface. So this is
a s logic analyzer and I just made a
little header that plugs in there that
taps off of that and then the computer
plugs into the other side of it right
there and I just listen in to see what's
happening. Um so that I can, you know,
watch the watch the signals and and try
to figure it out. At first I didn't know
any of this stuff. So I have to
basically just look at it and set
different voltages and and see what
happens and then try to try to figure it
out from there.
Now, one thing of note, if you hook up
to anything that plugs into the wall, so
this power supply is plugged into the
wall, you do not want your computer or
anything else plugged in the wall. You
want it floating basically. Um, and
that's because like you could create a
ground loop of some kind based on these
signals you're tapping on here and blow
freaking everything up. Best case
scenario is you blow up the $50 power
supply. uh worst case is you blow up
your sy or your laptop. Um and so uh
yeah, anytime you're working on
something that's plugged in, um not so
much that like you'll get hurt, you
could get hurt. I mean, there could be
some high voltage that comes across, you
get shocked, but the the most likely
outcome I've seen is like you just blow
your you blow your crap up and that
sucks. So, be very conscious of if
something's plugged into the wall, um
how you're measuring it if you hook
stuff up to it.
Now, these are the signals, some of them
at least. This is the digital to analog
converter. Um, so basically how you set
the voltage. So there's one line that
you set low that's in enabled. So when
that goes low, essentially the power
supply is going to, you know, put out
whatever voltage you ask it to. When it
goes high, it falls back to about 20
volts. Um, so just 20 volts is coming
out of the power supply kind of at all
times. And it'll show you that on that
little red screen. Then there's a clock
signal that's fed in, a data signal, and
then a strobe. And so some of this I I
was able to figure out what's going on
because I just looked up the data sheet
for the chip that's ultimately being
driven on that board. And the data sheet
for it also kind of tells you how it
works. And so it takes a 12bit um
12 bits of data. Basically this weird
spacing here is just some artifact of
the Motorola 6800 probably is it has
some interrupts and it's task swapping
or whatever they're doing in there. So
it it basically hits three bits of the
clock and then there's a pause and the
rest and the the chip that's receiving
it doesn't care. And so this is just
setting you know it starts here. So zero
or so 1 2 4 8. So this is just setting
the value 10 to the the the the DAC and
it can go from 0 to 4095 the 12 bits and
then it sends this little strobe and
that's what basically locks the value in
and tells you know the um digital analog
converter starts putting out that
voltage. And so depending on what you
set from 0 to 4,95 is how you set it
from about 20 volts which is the low end
to 3,000 volts. So, it turns out that
kind of like every DAC increment, so
30,0001,
30002 or whatever on the deck is about
a.7 volt uh change in the output of the
power supply. Um, I measured, you know,
the the signals themselves. These are
all on the wiki, so you can see for like
the data timing, the clock timing, all
of that stuff in between.
Um and and that's how I essentially um
wrote the kind of like the driver for it
based on the timing that that it's
sending um from the the Motorola
processor. Now to hook it up um all I'm
using here is the the Raspberry Pi Pico.
So this could just be any board with a
Pi Pico on it. Um I just happen to have
this thing built like as I built a few
of these myself, had some boards made.
So it was just like, okay, I'll I'll
solder this part. So on the back here,
I've just soldered wires to to this. it
goes to this little interface board. The
interface board is just to drive the
optoouplers.
Um, and so it's it's what you need to
interface with the optoouplers, whether
it's driving the LED side or receiving
from the other side. And then you this
should look familiar. This is literally
from inside the power supply that's
going to here.
Someone asked in the chat, "What speed
is that?" Um,
I don't know what you're asking. Maybe
speed of the the digital to analog
stuff. I mean, it updates like I think
the Motorola processor updated like
every 60 milliseconds or something that
it was sending. Oh, the DAC data
frequency. It's pretty slow. I don't
know exactly what it is. You can see on
the richest wiki what the timing works
out to, but I mean it's literally from a
Motorola processor running at like 4 MHz
or something. So, anything nowadays
could could drive it. Um, so, you know,
yeah, whatever you got. Now, I took that
information and I literally just uh used
Claude code. Um, I started as a base
with the PI Pico the Rasp Yeah, the Pico
EMP firmware. So, I thought what I was
going to do is have the Pico EMP sitting
kind of where it normally is and just
run a cable from it into the power
supply, but I thought that's probably a
long way to run that cable from the
power supply and and the the the kind of
triggering part of the Pico EMP and the
computer part, I don't need them in the
same place. So, I just need a
programmable power supply. Um, so just
like a, you know, basically a USB port
on the front of this power supply for me
to set it. And I'm going to trigger the
pico EMP using the chip whisperer. So it
doesn't even need a computer. Um, and so
I fed this timing information to Claude.
I went back and forth a little bit. I
came up with an interface. Um, this is
just a serial interface you get. This is
on my GitHub. Um, so you can download
this and and install it. Um, and uh, it
lets you do a few things.
So, um, it lets you come here and and
turn the the high voltage on and off.
Set a voltage. So, what voltage do you
want? That's what you saw me do earlier.
I can set like a soft limit. So, the
power supply goes to 3,000 volts. You do
not accidentally want to fat finger in
30,000 instead of 300 because bye-bye uh
circuit board that you had hooked up
there. Um, and so I I basically added in
some stuff so you can limit it so it
won't let you type in a a value you
shouldn't. Um, you can read the voltage
and the current level. So, when you're
when you're doing this glitch stuff in
your loop, you can set the voltage. You
can then do a read, ensure it's at
whatever you want. Um, this is more
setup stuff. So, this will let you just
write a value to the DAC, the digital
analog converter, or read back its
current value. Um, that's dangerous. You
use it in the configuration process, but
you can just literally type anything to
it. So, you want to make sure nothing's
plugged in except for like maybe a tool
you're using to measure the voltage as
you're um doing this next part I'll talk
about. Um because yeah, this this has no
protection. This is like a you're
writing directly to it. Um and then
there's a ramp function I added. So,
when you go from like 100 to 500 volts,
how quickly do you want it to get there?
Um you know, because maybe there'd be
some overshoot or something like that.
So, I just let you kind of set a value
if you want to smooth it. There's this
calibration area. This is where you
basically say this DAC value equals this
voltage. And so you build a little table
doing this and it's on the GitHub. It
shows you how to do it. Um, and then you
can check if there's any faults. So if
you if you short something, if you um if
it's open or whatever, this it'll read
back as a fault from the supply. Um, or
I just put a mode in there to ignore it
because like I really don't care if it
sees a temporary short or if it sees
something that's open. Um, I just want
it to do what I'm telling it to do.
Let me take a look see if there's any
questions real quick before I move on.
Um
says, "Should I try to make my own logic
analyzer or just buy one of those cheap
clones?" Um if you can support symmet
um you know get some cheap clone or
whatever. I I'm a fan of just buying
buying tools honestly. Um, and I'm a fan
of buying the best tool you can because
there's nothing worse than spending
hours trying to freaking fix something
that wasn't a something at all. Um, and
I got some stories about that. Um, but
you know, get the get the best tools you
can afford. You'll, you know, it's
possible if you buy a good tool. Like I
bought I bought one of the original
salies when it was like it's the 16 you
saw on there. Um, when the price was
like I guess I can't remember what I
paid. I didn't pay the the current price
or whatever, but I bought it, I don't
know, 6 8 10 years ago or something. It
still is like a fantastic tool. Every
time I use it, it's fantastic. Um, and
so a lot of my stuff is like that. It's
going to last a long time. So, um, spend
some cash and and get some good tools,
you know? I mean, depending on how into
this stuff you are. Um,
but yeah, your time is the most valuable
thing. if you if you're trying to save
money to save time, it's like you will
not end up saving time in the long run.
That's a virtual guarantee. Um so so
invest uh invest in yourself.
So here's here's just kind of a rough
breakdown. So we went from one to a,000
pulses per second. It's a $50 Pico EMP.
That's the cost to get one of these when
they're in stock. Um you might have to
build one yourself, but still around
that price. I put 150 for the power
supply. They're all over the place right
now for under hundred bucks and and you
know it's a little bit to ship it but at
some point they'll they'll disappear or
the price will go up but there's other
electrofaresis power supplies too. You
would just have to reverse engineer it
and figure out how to drive it. But they
all kind of they seem I bought a
different one um that I'm going to look
at as well. They seem to have this split
between the computer side and the high
voltage side. And then they're not
trying to protect it. It's not like a an
Xbox you got to break into like it's
just you know you just got to figure out
how they're driving it. Um, and then I
put 50 bucks for wires, resistors, and
caps, and a fan and stuff. If you're
somebody who's building this stuff, I'm
guessing you probably have that in a
box. Um, but if you got to buy, there
you go. And if you want to put it on one
of these platforms like I have, it's
kind of nice. I just drive it around
literally like with a joystick. You can
also automate it with your code to scan
and stuff, but um, for a couple hundred
bucks, that pushes you up a little bit.
But, um, but you don't need it. If you
watch the last talk I did on the
automotive car computer hacking, I
didn't have that at all. I literally had
a machinist arm holding the Pico EMP and
I just positioned the thing uh manually
myself and slid it around.
Now, um I did want to touch on this a
little bit um which is even though this
thing has crazy performance, actually
I'm just going to look at the
temperature here. Yeah, it's fine still.
Even though this thing has like a
thousand pulses per second, it doesn't
replace a chip shouter in my mind. At
least not the way it not as it sits
right now. Um, and that's because um I
mean you saw like the the pulse the
pulse kind of control the shape its
repeatability. It's got awesome thermal
design. Um the measurement capabilities
are huge as you're trying to see how how
does this pulse kind of actually um look
when it's coming out. You can do a
little bit of that with the Hfield Pro,
but not quite as nice. Um, and so having
had one myself, if you're someone that's
going to start doing um electromagnetic
fault injection on targets just with
today's this video date that you're
watching today's landscape, I don't know
about the future. Um, this is the to me
this is the tool you get. Um, you you'd
be crazy you're crazy efficient with it.
It's got all the kind of stuff you need.
It's easy to control all that. So, I
don't, you know, I wouldn't say like,
ah, I don't need this anymore. Um, now I
do think this setup could be a good like
backup. That's how I'm using it. When I
don't need chip shouter level attack
performance or whatever, and I just need
raw one kind of glitch, I'm trying to
attack something, this thing's great.
Um, if you're just a hobbyist, like
you're getting into this stuff. But I I
would say if you're someone that wants
to get into electrome fault injection,
this is the entry point. Like just a
faulty cat or just a pico EMP to me is
not the entry point because it will be
so slow, it's so frustrating that you'll
probably give up. Like it takes a a
freaking psychopath to stick with a tool
like that. Um and and just you know the
uh internal struggle. you got to be a
freaking SATA mass, I guess, to like use
that tool. This um you could just be
kind of like a a person who wants to
learn and you'll be able to move at a
speed where um it's not as frustrating.
And so, you know, I would say like uh
yeah, I don't want to discourage you
from experimenting because obviously you
can with those other tools, but if you
really have something you're trying to
attack or you have a goal in mind, this
is a a wise investment to get you closer
to to achieving your goal.
Um, so this was kind of more for
hardware IO to show some signals and
performance. Um, but it's kind of nice
to see like how how does it stack up
side by side. So, um, so just a reminder
on this setup. Um, someone said you're
going to give us a write up on this. So,
some of the stuff is written up like on
the um on the chest wiki there's kind of
the the tear down stuff on the GitHub.
Um there's the code and everything um
for you to you know put in there and uh
use um the rough write up or something.
I might create a wiki page that just is
a document of setting all this up. So it
kind of depends um you know what people
are interested in or whatever. But I'm
not opposed to kind of just a a wiki
entry that's like a getting started
guide for all of this stuff that breaks
down and also you know kind of a really
maybe budgetary friendly getting started
guide. So, if you don't have all this
equipment, but you want to set something
up, what is it? How do you plug it all
in? How do you make sure it's working?
Something like that. So, um yeah.
Okay. So, um this here is um like I
said, the function generator. So, this
is what I'm using to generate the the
the timing of the pulses, how many are
happening per second. This is what I'm
using to define the width of the pulse
that's going to that the device is going
to send. Um this is the probe that I'm
using to measure kind of in open air.
this electromagnetic pulse that's being
uh sent out. Um, and it's going into my
oscilloscope. It's kind of going
directly from the probe into the scope.
And so this right here, these are some
attenuators so that the the voltage
spike that's being induced in that probe
doesn't blow up uh my oscilloscope. And
these are just like some cheapy inline
SMA attenuators I got from some kit. I
think right now it's 3dB. I actually
pumped it up. Currently, what's on there
is like 10 dB um of attenuation.
So, here's three pulses side by side.
So, this is the Pico EMP
just by itself. One one hertz, one pulse
per second. It's kind of it's kind of
janky, you know. Um you see the pulse
gets sent and then it's like going
through all this kind of ringing and
stuff um that happens. This is the
modified Pico EMP. So, a much nicer
pulse. There's some ringing here. Some
of this stuff can be artifacts of how
it's hooked up to my oscilloscope and
stuff. So, it's kind of tough to to say
completely. Um, but, you know, it's a
much tighter pulse on off. I've done a
couple other little tweaks I'll talk
about. This green line is the the
voltage uh measurement that's being
pumped into it. Um, and then this is the
pulse. Same. Everything's the same. the
the width of what I'm asking for. This
is from the chip shouter. The only thing
is this is zoomed in a little tighter
here. So, this is 100 ncond spacing here
and here I'm zoomed in a little more.
So, that's uh 100 um but but very nice
shape. The difference is I'm pumping
this thing at 5,000 pulses per second
right now. This is no I didn't even hook
up the cooling. The chip shter has a
cool port on top. You literally hook up
an air supply to feed into it and it has
active cool, you know, basically you can
provide an active cooling supply. This
is without providing anything. Now, um
it's at some point it does overheat at
this kind of 5,000 per second pulse rate
because I didn't provide any cooling,
but it's crazy that like you know this
pulse shape with its own internal high
voltage power supply is it just stays
rock solid. Um is what you're what
you're doing there.
Um now the where the chip shouter starts
to shine
um is when you want to send more than
one pulse. So when we go back here to me
if you can send a thousand pulses per
second like you just do the math on the
timing that means every one millisecond
you're able to send another fault. when
you're doing fault injection, like
there's setup times. Um, you might be
sending, you know, a serial password and
then you do a fault and then you're
checking to see whether you got in or
not, all of that stuff isn't happening
in one millisecond usually. So, if you
can send a,000 pulses per second, like
you're probably fine. You It's not
likely that you need 5,000 or whatever
because just the rest of the attack
chain is going to take some amount of
time. even probably 250 500 depending on
what you're doing. 100 per second might
be the max you could do. Um,
but when you have an attack where you're
going to send a fault and that kind of
moves you a little further into the
code, but then you're going to get
kicked out somewhere else and you need
to send another fault. That is where you
start to get like where the chip shouter
shines. Um, because like the picomp
that's not even an option, right? one
pulse per second. Right now, without
kind of any optimizing, keeping the the
the shape of the pulse I'm asking for
the same with um the supercharged PCMP,
I can send a second pulse and get about
the same results of the the kind of the
pulse magnitude and everything
microsconds.
There's some things I can do to tweak it
to get it closer. Um but if I ask for
the same size pulse, it takes about
every 20 micros. It's probably every 25
cuz you can see the high voltage is
starting to kind of dip a little bit
like the capacitors can't quite recharge
fast enough with what I have set up. Um,
with that kind of little rudimentary
thing, this is the chip shouter. It can
do it every 150 nanoseconds and get the
same pulse. As you start to do more, it
it changes. So, there's a lot of like
you have to start to understand the
capabilities of the tool and what you're
asking for, but this is in the same
terms. This is 20,000 nanoseconds. So
when you want to like do these very
complex attacks that require multiple um
attack points and things like that, the
chip shatter is like it's just a tool
that's going to get it done. Um that
doesn't mean that this couldn't in the
future. Um but it's definitely not going
to be able to without some serious uh
pretty serious modifications. I would
say not the same board anymore at that
point. You're not slapping on one or two
parts, I don't think. Um, somebody could
prove me wrong, but I don't believe
you're that's going to be the case
now. So, what then? What would be the
ultimate platform? To me, this is the
ultimate platform.
You don't need like I don't need all
this extra circuitry. I don't need all
this stuff. Like, what I need is a board
that can take a trigger.
uh it you know it needs some low voltage
power supply 10 15 volts whatever for a
driver circuit and it needs a high
voltage input. I don't need any computer
on this. I don't need anything. Um I
just need to be able to send pulses out.
Um and so to me like this is the most
economical way to do this and also the
safest to sell because there's no high
voltage or anything on here. You have
this this little basically attack board.
So, what are my assumptions? Um, my
assumptions are that this isn't the only
thing you're buying. So, a Pico EMP, you
can just buy that, right? My assumptions
are someone that when you're doing this,
you've probably done some voltage fault
injection. Like, you already have a chip
whisper. So, you already have something
that's coordinating. I have a trigger
and I want to send a glitch. Um, you
probably already have power supplies.
Like, you're having to power whatever
boards you're using right now. So you
don't need, it doesn't need its own low
voltage kind of power supply stuff like
that. And you can buy one of these
cheapy high voltage power supplies and
set yourself up there. What you need is
the thing that takes that and allows you
to just have an epic uh EMP platform
that can send rapid multiple pulses, you
know, anything you want. Basically, you
send a digital pulse in and it just
replicates it with a high voltage pulse
coming out.
the the piece that I think sets apart um
one of the key parts that sets apart the
chip shouter is this is the driver
circuit
for the MOSFET that does the the
switching um the the Pico EMP's driver
circuit is is way way kind of simpler
than this and so this actually has a
proper driver chip to set the you know
to basically drive it on and drive it
off super fast. Um, and it's, you know,
I think it's running like a 19vt rail.
Um, so, so it's like a vastly superior
driver circuit that makes a massive
difference. Even calling calls out here
like that tuning this is part of the
magic. Like this is where you know that
you separate um the toys from the tools.
So you need but the cool thing is that
the chip shatter is an open- source
hardware device. So like this is their
schematic, right? So you could build
that circuit um and try to incorporate
it.
What the heck? Oh, hang on a second. My
uh
my Dio crashed here.
Sometimes this happens with like Keynote
I got I got so much multimedia and
whatever in this freaking presentation
that it uh it crapped itself out. Let me
open it back up here real quick.
Where the heck are we?
We're here.
How about now? All right.
Okay. The other thing um you need is um
well, I think on this little board, you
need like some pool of capacitors. So
the power supply, the way I have it now,
the power supply is kind of far away in
the sense of like it's like 2 feet of
wire. So you know, you you need some
kind of like you have this high voltage
power supply. It's going to charge up a
bank of capacitors that is like your
supply bank for your uh pulsing
capacitors. Um and so I I I feel like
that's probably the simplest way to
solve this problem. So the power supply
ensures that this pool is always filled
up and then this pool supplies what's
actually being attacked. Um maybe not. I
haven't I haven't kind of started to
design this thing myself, but that's
just my gut feeling. Um is some kind of
some kind of buffer um versus and that
way that big power supply can kind of
sit somewhere further away. You don't
need it right next to you. Um someone
said, "Please don't delete this live
stream after this ends." I won't you
might see it disappear for a moment
because I might have to trim it a little
bit um in the beginning or something if
it's too much time before we get
started. Um but otherwise, yeah, I'll uh
I'll leave it up. And I also turned off
the uh monetization on this thing, so it
shouldn't be hitting you with a bunch of
ads. If it is, it's not cuz I did it. Um
so that you can watch it.
Um the other piece that's key to me is
this oscilloscope monitoring. So these
are the outputs that are on the chip
shouter. It's really nice. They got
these little things you plug in. They
give you a couple of probes. You hook to
your oscilloscope and you're able to see
basically what's happening inside as you
as you know what's the voltage level,
what's the current, you know, doing as
you're as you're pumping into this
thing. So you can adjust how wide is
your glitch. And this can change like
you could have a 200 u nancond wide
glitch at 200 volts just fine. um or at
500 volts it can only be 100 nanoseconds
wide and that's because ultimately it's
like the overall power that you're
driving into this coil that's on the
bottom which is just an inductor. Um and
so you can only drive it so much before
it saturates and then you you start to
see this happen with the current. Um but
this is amazing. Now it's not super
complex like when you look at the
schematic of the chip shatter um this
isn't a massively complex thing to add.
Um so I think this would also be cool.
Um, it wasn't shown in my little diagram
there. I should put like a thing that
comes off the side that says um,
measurement outputs. Um, but for sure
this is awesome to have.
Um, and then, you know, finally, heat
dissipation. So, if you're doing a,000
pulses per second or whatever, um, the
board just needs to be designed this
way. This isn't a big deal. Um, this one
was designed with um, safety, you know,
in mind, right, as like the top priority
for the Pico EMP. So, they don't do
there's, you know, behind the little um,
chip. Let's see if I have one. Do I have
a board sitting here? I do. Okay, let me
switch to Let me see if I switch to this
thing here.
Okay, here we go. So, here here's the uh
here's the the board. How how do I get
this thing to not suck? There we go. So,
you see that right there on the back.
It's just completely smooth, right? So,
they don't have any the the MOSFET
that's right there. um where it says
high voltage, there's not even anything
going through that's like a heat sink on
the board where normally you would have
it coming through the back here like
with VAS and and this back area would be
a big thing of metal. Um they do that to
protect you so you don't shock the crap
out of yourself and and they cover that
up. So So basically if you did a
different board design um you could, you
know, uh you could basically, you know,
make it much better from a thermal
perspective. Put a heat sink on it. um
throw a fan in there, whatever it is. Um
but that that would make a massive a
massive difference. Um and then you
wouldn't, you know, and you could also
put just like a little thermister or
something on there. So it could be part
of the the monitoring output that that
comes from it if you want to do that.
Now, what's not needed to me is like any
kind of a brain um or a a digital
interface or whatever. So, the chip
shatter has a ton of interesting things
it can do. I mean, you can even like
they have a bit stream where you can
like program one one
and it's in like 20 nancond
uh increments. So, you can define these
kind of chains of pulses and whatever in
there. Um, I haven't played with it a
ton, so I don't know if there's some
amazing extra effect you get with that
versus just driving it from a chip
whisper, but for basically everything
I've done and for a lot of the attacks
you would use for something that's in
this mid-range cost, I think it doesn't
need a brain. Like, you just drive the
MOSFET itself from the the trigger
glitch output on your Chip Whisperer or
whatever you're using. Um, I don't think
you need a high voltage power supply,
obviously, because we can buy these
things. Um, I mean, even if you buy one
that's just all done, like if you look
on Amazon or AliExpress or Alibaba or
whatever, there's these high voltage
power supplies that'll go up to like 600
volts. They're computer controlled over
USB. I don't know how uh how well they
work, but as long as you can set it, you
know, one or two volts at a time in
increments, and it won't die, you know,
or or it won't freak out when you kind
of just short it quickly, those you can
get for like four or 500 bucks brand
new. Um, so even if you don't do the
eBay thing for 50 bucks or whatever, so
it's still you're still, you know, an
order of magnitude cheaper than a $5,000
chip shouter.
And I don't think you need, you know,
like this massive amount of safety on
this kind of board. You need something.
You need some way to enclose it so that,
you know, you don't just accidentally
touch something once you've hooked it
up. and maybe some SMA connectors or
something for feeding in the high
voltage so you can kind of just get
everything attached and and you look at
that. Um, but to me it's like this is
like a welder to me. Like there's only
so much safety you can put on a welder.
Like you can burn the [__] out of
yourself. You can shock yourself. It's
like it's a tool. You need to understand
how to use it. You need to understand
that the thing you weld gets crazy hot.
You need to know about fumes. Like
there's some onus put on the user. And
I'm fine honestly putting that onus on
people. like here's this thing, it can
kill you. Don't touch here. Um, and if
you and if you're not aware, like you
know, stupid eliminates people from the
population. So, uh, don't be stupid.
Um, now, a little bit on what to look
for when buying a power supply. Um,
because there's a lot of these as you
start to Google search. Um, if you look
for the 3000XI, that's obviously the
exact same one that you see here that I
have. Um, pay attention to the model
numbers. Um, especially as you're
looking at these things. Um, there's a
lot of different biorads and and other
ones I'm sure will work and they might
have a similar interface. They go up to
different voltage levels. Um, I don't
know exactly how these levels impact
what you're able to do from a biology
perspective, but there are a bunch of
different kind of voltage levels. Um, if
you're if you're just somebody that
likes to hack on stuff and reverse
engineer things like there are others
that are out there. I'll show you one
that I just bought. I haven't looked at
it at all. So, I got no idea if um if
this one sucks or not, but here you go.
You see, let's see. Let me rotate it.
One second.
This thing right here. I don't know.
EC4000P.
Um,
I popped it open real quick and it has a
similar interface. You know, there's a
computer part of it, there's the high
voltage part of it. It's probably not
that hard. Like it's, you know, hook up
the hook up the logic analyzer, see what
the heck it's doing, build a little
interface board for it, clog code up
some interface to it. Um, and there you
go. And so, um, you know, I'll probably
I'll add that one to the wiki at some
point. Um, but you know, uh, don't buy
that one with like the anticipation that
I'm going to do the work. Like if you
buy that one, that's on you. The one
that's up there now is is what's up
there. But, um, but likely you can make
a lot of these work. And the cool thing
is I think there's just a huge amount of
these things that are on the surplus
market. They've been out for years. I
saw an old Eevee um, blog post about it
on like their forum where somebody
bought one and they were like, "Wow,
these things are freaking amazing. Why
isn't anybody buying these?" Um, and
this is like after I bought mine. And I
think it's probably because these don't
have any kind of computer control,
right? And and I'm sure the biology
experiments, the software they use,
everything else has moved on at this
point to they just sell you ones that
have computer control and you're not
typing anything on the front of these
and software is managing all of it. And
so these ones are kind of ripe for just
us using a Pi Pico or whatever the hell
board you want to use. Um, you could
probably do an ESP32 and just make it
wireless. Like literally anything could
run this thing. Um, and so it's just up
to you what you want to what you want to
code to to make it run. Wireless might
honestly be the best option because then
you are completely isolated from the
control side even though this has the
optos and everything. But yeah, kind of
up to you what you want to do there.
Um, and so the reason I do a lot of this
like this kind of sharing and trying to
push the price of the tools down is that
like I think back when I was like a kid
um and that the toughest thing was
accessibility.
Like it it's not that somehow I'm so
much smarter uh than somebody else
that's out there. Like I'm the same as
you most likely. Like I'm just I just
sit here and work on this stuff. And the
maybe the difference is I just refuse to
stop. But anybody can do that. That
that's not like, you know, it's not like
I'm a gifted person in that respect,
right? So it's that now I have these
tools. Like I have a job where I can
just buy this stuff. Um and then I can
experiment with it. But when I was a
kid, I had nothing but time and and no
money. And and so it's like if you can
just do a little money and you and
you're willing to invest the time, you
can now attack things and and do attacks
that are only available to ones that
are, you know, much higher up. And so,
you know, the that's a big driver for me
sharing. And I would say for you, it's
like, you know, share the share the
stuff you do, post things you do, put it
on the wiki, put it somewhere. Um
because you know, the the next person
that might do an interesting attack uh
might do it with something that's very
cheap.
So, uh, thanks for watching. Um, we can
take a look at the thermals on this
thing real quick, um, since we're done.
Otherwise, uh, I'll probably let this
I'll let the stream run as I show you a
couple of these things. Feel free to ask
any questions. I'll take a look here and
see. Um, the GitHub repo. Yeah, let me
show you that real quick. Give me one
second.
This is the GitHub repo. It's my GitHub.
Bitbanging bytes, which is literally
what we do in this thing. Uh we bit bang
our uh our control over there. And then
bioad PSU controller. Um it's public.
You can see here. I mean, so the whole
thing was clawed coded. So don't look at
the code expecting uh some I don't know.
It's probably written better honestly
than I would have done it. But um but I
did have it kind of clean it up. I
changed this interface. There is one bug
I've noticed um that happened recently
as I made some changes right before that
I have to fix. So within the next day or
two I'll I'll fix that and push it where
it's like if you set if you turn the
high voltage supply on and you set the
voltage after maybe 5 minutes it just
stops responding to the set voltage
command and you have to do HVD to
disable it and then HVE to turn it back
on and it's fine again. But that's just
some little bug that I'll I'll fix real
quick. It's not a big deal. Um I show
you here kind of this table. So this is
what I'm talking about how I profile it.
So I would set a DAC voltage. So I'd set
a DAC value. So I would say 100. I'd
look at the voltage that I see on the um
voltmeter and I would say okay at this
value it's 61 volts. And so I enter and
put it in a table. And then it says okay
when I see this PWM frequency coming
from the supply that correlates to this.
After some number of these measurements
you basically just built like an
interpolation table. And so then you can
type in any voltage you want and it will
interpolate that to what the closest DAC
value is um and and give it to you. And
so that's that's basically how how it
works. It's you know it's a pretty
simple uh kind of thing. I'm sure if you
if you write code and you're familiar
with this stuff, there's some badass
stuff you could do of like literally
monitoring the PWM outputs, driving it
based on what you see there because this
thing supports like constant current,
constant voltage. It has all kinds of
cool things that it's doing looking at
those outputs. You could do that same
stuff with a a Pi Pico. I just didn't uh
I didn't need it, I guess, and I
probably ran out of time, so I was like,
forget it. Like, this is good enough. It
lets me set the voltage and and based on
what I'm doing, it kind of holds the the
voltage there. Anyways,
let me see if I can pull this thing up
here real quick.
Um,
let's see what else somebody say. Could
you get better uh better performance
with better cooling at a th00and? Um I
don't think the performance would change
honestly like the the performance as I'm
judging it is the shape of the pulse. So
here's the here's a pulse. Let me just
adjust this.
Yeah. So, this thing here, this this
pulse, the yellow, kind of look at the
yellow. The blue is the digital signal
I'm sending in. The yellow is what the
Hfield probe is picking up. You can kind
of see this second little hump. That's
because at this voltage level, I'm I'm
basically driving it a little too long.
And so, you're seeing it kind of start
to do that saturate thing. Um,
but that if the shape of the pulse was
like taking a crap or something or
looking weird as it got hotter, then I
would say maybe cooling it more would do
something. But the shape of the pulse
isn't changing. So, um, so I don't think
cooling it would do anything extra for
it. Um, you just I'm just thinking more
longevity. you might run a a campaign
that is like uh
hours or something and so you just want
to ensure that the thing it's not so
close to the edge of where it is from a
heat perspective that it just burns
itself out or whatever, right? Um
so let's see. Maybe I'll move the
microphone over here real quick.
So we're at 20 hertz. Let's see.
Temperature- wise,
what are we at?
30 30C. So, yeah, nothing really. I
mean, this you you put your hand on, you
wouldn't even like without a thermal
gun, you wouldn't even know anything was
going on with this thing right now. Um,
so let's like pump it up to
like up to 100, 90, 100. Okay. So,
now let me adjust my trigger level. You
see this kind of it's saying like it
it's at a uh it's at a different
frequency there. So let me adjust the
trigger so that we're up here a little
higher.
So now we should be 100. Yeah. 100
hertz. Okay. And then if we look we see
are we starting to get a little hotter?
Yeah. 36 39. And this is without the
little fan running that's uh that's
sitting right there. So, if you kick
that little fan on, I have it hooked up.
Like I say, it's like I don't need power
supplies, man. Like, I got power
supplies. I'm sure you got freaking wall
warts sitting a thousand of them um in a
drawer somewhere. So, I just hit this
thing
and then I kind of just turn this thing
on low and then even with it on low,
it'll like start to cool down.
Yeah. And you know, it's like you can
kick it up and so then you can run for a
long time. So, it's like Yeah. It's just
some good uh some good thermals would uh
would go a long way because it's like
also too it's like you just want as many
as much thermal as you can have. Sorry.
You want like as much thermal as you can
have without having fans running cuz
Jesus Christ like fans will make you go
insane, you know. Um and so even in the
um even in the bio you can unplug its
fan. And so for a lot of my testing, I
just had the fan unplugged and the top
propped open a little bit so the heat
could escape cuz it's like you just
going to take that for so long. Um,
let's see. I think that's uh I think
that's it.
Yeah. So if you have questions on this
stuff, um, obviously Riches has a
Discord. Let me see if pull that up. you
go to uh
chess.com
has a discord um and the wiki like you
saw. Um you can join in there and and
chat with people, ask questions, um
stuff like that. Um and yeah, I'd look
forward to seeing other people build
this. I know of a number of people that
bought the supply. just for your your
own uh knowledge, here's here's how this
went out. So, on Patreon, for people
that are Patreons, I posted a week,
three maybe a few days to a week before
I went to Hardware.io and I said, I'm
going to go give a talk on this. This is
a supply that I'm going to talk about.
If you want one, get them while they're
still cheap. Then I went to Hardware.io.
I gave the talk. It wasn't, you know,
it's not streamed live. I said, "Hey,
you're here in this room. If you want to
do this, uh, get one of these power
supplies because they're available and
real cheap. Um, now word to YouTube,
you're on the live stream. If this is
something you're actually going to do,
buy one of these power supplies while
they're still cheap. Um, once it, you
know, once everybody else sees it, uh,
you know, we're going to be reverse
engineering a different power supply
because they'll be gone cuz they're
they're dirt cheap right now. And it's a
badass power supply. Like 20 to 3,000
volts programmed over, you know, a
serial port to your computer. Who cares
if you're doing this? Like you could be
doing anything you need a high voltage
power supply for. It literally is 400
watts. It's a crazy high voltage power
supply for 50 bucks. Um so, oh, one
thing is it's only this one's 120 volts.
They make a 240 volt model when you look
at their manual. Um but, uh I haven't I
haven't seen any for sale. So, if you're
not, you know, you're not on 120 for
power, um you might have to look at a
different supply or or something else
like that.
Um,
all right. So, I'm gonna I'm gonna cut
it. Appreciate uh appreciate you hanging
out. Like the questions. If you have
more, hit [snorts] me on Discord.